The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
-- talking about molecular
orbital theory.
And remember what the key idea
was, there?
The key idea was to take the
wave functions,
the atomic wave functions,
the wave functions on the atoms
that are going to form this
chemical bond.
Take those wave functions and
let them overlap.
Let them constructively and
destructively interfere.
After all, they are waves.
They are wave functions.
They can constructively and
destructively interfere.
And we saw last time that when
these atomic wave functions
constructively interfered,
the result was a molecular wave
function that was a bonding wave
function.
Consequently,
it had a bonding state.
For example,
in the case of oxygen,
we had the 2s wave functions on
each of the isolated oxygen
atoms.
When they overlap,
they can constructively
interfere to form a sigma 2s
bonding wave function.
And, consequently,
a sigma 2s bonding state.
And there are two electrons in
that.
And you will remember that we
labeled the molecular states
with respect to the symmetry of
the wave function around the
molecular axis.
That wave function was sigma if
that symmetry was cylindrical
around the molecular axis.
It was pi here in this case for
molecular oxygen when the wave
function was not cylindrically
symmetric around the bond axis.
And we also saw what happened
when these two wave functions
come together.
They overlap and they
destructively interfere.
When they destructively
interfere, we form what we
called an antibonding wave
function.
We gave it a designation star.
In the case here of the 2s
electrons or wave functions in
oxygen, this formed the sigma 2s
star wave
function, the antibonding wave
function.
Its energy is higher than that
of the atomic states for the two
separated oxygen atoms.
The bonding state is lower in
energy.
The antibonding state is higher
in energy.
And so this was for the 2s
electrons.
Below this lower energy,
because they're more strongly
bond, are the 1s atomic states
and the molecular states formed
by the constructive and
destructive interference with
the 1s wave function.
I didn't draw that.
2s, then, is higher in energy.
And finally,
here are the 2p states that are
coming together in molecular
oxygen, forming a sigma 2pz and
then two molecular states,
pi 2py and a pi 2px.
And then in molecular oxygen,
we also saw that there was one
electron each here in the pi
star 2px and pi star 2py.
Now, I just wanted to say a few
words here about the physical
significance of these energies
here.
This is the molecular orbital
in the case of molecular oxygen
here.
This is the molecular state
that is highest occupied.
What we mean by highest
occupied is that it is the state
that is the highest lying in
energy.
It has an electron in it that
is the highest lying in energy.
What this binding energy means
is, or what this energy means is
that if I put in energy to pull
this electron,
the one that is highest lying
in energy off,
the energy from here to O two
plus plus an electron,
this physically is the
ionization energy of O two.
Because the first ionization
energy is always the energy
required to take off the most
weakly bond electron or the
electron in the most highest
lying energy state.
So that is the ionization
energy of O two.
That turns out to be about
12.01 electron volts.
That is what that physically
means.
In contrast here,
if I were to pull an electron
off of an oxygen atom,
these are the oxygen atom
states, so I have O plus
plus an electron,
well, this is the ionization
energy of oxygen.
This is a little bit larger
than it is for molecular O two.
This is 13.58 eV.
And you can see that here.
These 2p states are lower lying
in energy than the pi states in
the molecular oxygen.
This isn't in your notes,
Okay?
And, likewise,
if I were to look at the
electron affinity of oxygen.
Now I am just going to draw
here the pi star 2px,
pi star 2py.
And here are my atomic states.
Here are the other two pi's.
Here is the sigma.
Here is oxygen.
If I were to look at the
electron affinity of oxygen,
molecular oxygen,
so way up here I have an O two
molecule plus an
electron.
Putting in an electron in,
I would have to put it in that
state.
And so the energy difference
here, from here to here,
is minus the electron affinity,
which is, in the case of
molecular oxygen,
minus 0.045 eV.
I just wanted to give you a
feeling for what these energies
actually mean.
We are not plotting them as a
function of energy here.
But they physically mean
something in terms of,
for example,
the ionization energy of
molecular oxygen or the
ionization energy of atomic
oxygen.
You can see the relative orders
of the energies of all of these
different states.
This kind of diagram that we
have been drawing here sometimes
is called a molecular orbital
energy diagram.
Sometimes it is called the
correlation diagram.
It is called a correlation
diagram because it shows you,
by the means of these kind of
dotted lines here,
how the atomic states correlate
to the molecular states.
That is why it is called the
correlation diagram,
again.
It shows you how those atomic
states correlate to the
molecular states.
Questions?
Okay.
If not then I want to proceed.
There was one page on the
lecture last time that I had not
finished, so I want to talk
about that right now.
And that was drawing the
molecular orbital diagram,
or the correlation diagram for
a heteronuclear diatomic
molecule.
And that is CO.
In the case of the
heteronuclear diatomic molecule,
we proceed in the same way as
we do for a homonuclear diatomic
molecule.
That is, we had the states of
the individual atoms out here,
and now I am just showing you
the 2p states.
2s are down here.
1s is down here lower in
energy, but I haven't drawn it
all.
And what you also see is that
the 2p states on the oxygen atom
here are lower in energy than
the 2p states on the carbon.
And that's right.
Remember we talked about the
fact that as the nuclear charge
gets larger those atomic states
are more strongly bound,
because the Coulomb interaction
is greater.
So the atomic states of oxygen
are lower in energy than those
of carbon.
If you were asked to draw this
on a homework problem or on an
exam, you would have to show
that the oxygen atomic states
are lower in energy than those
for carbon.
But we proceed much in the same
way.
That is, the 2pz states here
overlap.
Remember, those are the states
that, by definition,
we are putting parallel or
along the bond axis.
So they overlap to form the
sigma 2pz wave function for the
molecule.
And then the 2pi x and 2pi y
are overlapping,
those are the ones coming in
like this, parallel to each
other, to form the pi 2px and pi
2py.
And likewise,
you have the antibonding
states.
These wave functions can
destructively interfere,
resulting in the antibonding pi
star 2px,
pi star 2py and
sigma star 2pz.
Now we've got all the states
there, and now we proceed using
the Aufbau Principle.
We start populating them,
lowest energy first until we
use up all the electrons.
We have got six electrons,
so we put two of them in that
lowest energy state and then the
other four here in these pi
states.
And that then is the
correlation diagram,
or just the top part of it for
this molecule CO.
And if I had to write the
electron configuration,
here it is.
Here is the sigma 1s 2,
sigma 1s star 2,
sigma 2s 2, sigma 2s star 2,
sigma 2pz 2,
pi 2px 2, pi 2py 2.
Now what
is the bond order?
Remember that was a measure
here of the strength of the
bond.
The bond order is one-half
times the number of bonding
electrons minus antibonding
electrons.
Well, in this case it is three,
right?
Because we have two,
four, six, eight,
ten bonding electrons.
We have two,
four antibonding electrons.
10 minus 4 is 6 divided by 2 is
3.
This is a triple bond.
And the binding energy here is
162 kilojoules.
This is the strongest bond
known, this triple bond here
between carbon and the oxygen.
Yes?
Most negative,
right.
No, the lowest energy is always
the more negative.
Great.
There is one other thing I want
to point out here.
Remember I talked about the
relative ordering of sigma and
pi, how in the case when Z
equals 8, the sigma level drops
below the pi level?
Well, that is true.
But here we have CO where one
of the atoms has Z equals 8 and
one of them is less than Z
equals 8.
What do we do in that case?
In that case we are going to
put the sigma lower than the pi.
We are going to follow the Z
equals 8 or greater rule when
you have a choice there.
That is the heteronuclear
diatomic molecule.
Now what we are going to do,
is we're going to leave
molecular orbital theory.
We are going to start talking
about larger molecules than
diatomic molecules.
And we have another approach
for these larger molecules.
And that is what is called a
valence bond method along with a
hybridization.
And I will explain that to you.
You can use the molecular
orbital approach for larger
molecules.
We are not going to do that.
It doesn't always work for
larger molecules.
Let me show you just an example
here when it doesn't work.
And that is the case of
methane.
Here I have just drawn a carbon
atom.
I show you the 2px and the 2pz
wave functions for a carbon.
And in the molecular orbital
approach, what did we do?
Well, what we did was let the
wave function from one atom
overlap with the wave function
from the other to form a new
molecular wave function.
And so that is what we would do
if we started with a molecular
orbital approach for methane.
We would let the 1s wave
function overlap with the 2pz on
the carbon, and over here the 1s
wave function overlap with the
2pz on the carbon.
But if we did that,
we are now stuck.
We are stuck because we don't
have another electron up here to
overlap.
We do not have another wave
function to overlap with the
hydrogen.
The electron configuration of
carbon is 2s,
two electrons in it,
and then one in one of the 2p
wave orbitals,
the other one in the other 2p
state.
If you use this molecular
orbital approach strictly on
methane, what it would predict
is that we could only make two
bonds to carbon.
And it would say methane is
really CH two and the
bond angle here is 90 degrees.
So molecular orbital theory,
at least on methane,
doesn't work,
although it does work for some
other polyatomic molecules.
That was just an example here
of how it doesn't work.
Now we are going to take an
approach that will work to
describe the chemical bonding in
methane, and that is this
hybridization coupled with what
we call the valence bond
approach.
Here is the important part.
Here is the atomic state for
carbon.
Notice two 2s electrons and
then one in each of the 2p
states.
The first thing that we are
going to do is we are going to
do an electron promotion.
We are going to take this
electron and put it up there.
That is electron promotion.
That costs energy.
Where did the energy come from?
I am going to tell you soon
where the energy comes from.
We're just going to do it now,
and then we will go back and
look at where the energy comes
from.
What we are then going to do is
draw out here each one of these
atomic wave functions.
I am drawing this atomic wave
function, this one,
this one and this one on the
next slide.
That is what this is.
Here is the 2s.
That is spherical.
Here is the 2pz we looked at
before.
Here is the 2ps.
Here is the 2py.
Those are the four atomic wave
functions.
Now what I am going to do,
and this is all on carbon,
we haven't formed any bonds
yet, is I am going to take these
four wave functions.
They are all on the same
carbon, but I am going to let
those four wave functions
constructively and destructively
interfere.
Now I am taking the wave
functions on the same atom and
letting them constructively and
destructively interfere.
In molecular orbital theory,
we took the wave functions on
different atoms and let them
constructively and destructively
interfere.
This is going to be taking the
wave functions on the same atom
and letting them constructively
and destructively interfere.
When I do this,
what you are going to get is
something that looks like this.
You are going to get four
different wave functions that we
are going to call the sp 3
wave functions,
or the sp 3 orbitals.
More precisely,
they are the four sp 3
hybrid wave functions or hybrid
orbitals.
Because they are this linear
combination, the overlap of
these four different wave
functions on the same carbon
atom to make four equivalent
hybrid wave functions that we
call sp 3 wave
functions.
They all look the same.
They are just oriented in space
a little differently.
To understand that,
and it is not clear,
I know, from looking at this,
how that gets like this.
But here is one simple way to
look at one of these.
Take this 2s wave function and
let it constructively and
destructively interfere with the
2pz wave function,
so this sphere is essentially
on top of here.
What you notice on the 2pz wave
function is that this part of
the wave function has got a
positive amplitude.
Remember, we talked about the
positive sign on one of these
lobes, meaning it had a positive
amplitude?
And this part of the wave
function, that has got a
negative sign,
it has a negative amplitude.
But the 2s wave function here
has a positive amplitude
everywhere.
If we put the 2s on top of
here, you can see that right
here we are going to have two
positives, amplitudes of two
waves that are positive.
They are going to
constructively interfere and the
result is above here,
right here, if you just take
these two and look at this,
you are going to have a lot of
wave function right up there.
However, below this plane where
we have a positive wave function
at the same part where we have a
negative wave function,
well, you know what,
this is destructive
interference.
And the result is that the wave
function here is going to be
pretty small.
It is still going to be a
little negative,
but it is going to be pretty
small.
That is probably the simplest
just example to look at so that
you understand how I get from
here to here.
So we are going to form these
four sp 3 wave
functions.
Here is a picture of that.
When I take these four wave
functions.
I have just separated them out
in space, but now I am really
just going to put them on top of
each other because they really
all have the same origin here.
When I do that,
my wave function kind of looks
like this, where these lobes
here are the positive parts.
They are my sp 3 wave
function.
And in this picture,
I left out the little negative
lobes that would be sticking out
here.
I left those out because it is
just too hard to draw this.
And what I want you to notice
here is that this angle from
here to here is 109.5 degrees.
This is a little bit better
picture that I didn't draw of
those sp 3 wave
functions.
In this case you can see a
little bit of the negative wave
function from this positive lobe
over here, and you can kind of
see the little negative here and
the little negative there.
That is a better picture than
the one I drew.
We have got this kind of
configuration,
here, with an angle of 109.5
from this lobe to that lobe or
this lobe to that lobe or this
lobe to that lobe.
And you can understand that
109.5 degrees if I do the
following, that is if I now draw
lines from the outer most point
of each lobe.
What you see is that I have a
tetrahedron now with carbon in
the center.
And each one of these vertices
here of this tetrahedron is at
the outermost points of these
wave functions.
The angle in a perfect
tetrahedron is 109.5 degrees.
That is where that 109.5
degrees comes from.
That is a tetrahedral
configuration around that
carbon.
What did we do here?
We took an electron.
We promoted it.
When then took these four wave
functions and let them
constructively and destructively
interfere.
The result now is four new wave
functions corresponding to four
new states.
Recalling these states,
sp 3 states.
There is one electron in each
one of those sp^3 states.
Where do these energies lie?
Well, they lie in between the
2s and the 2p.
They are not as high in energy
as the 2p, but they certainly
are higher than the 2s.
And, overall,
you can see we are still going
to have to need some energy
input into the system to make
this happen.
And I haven't told you yet
where that energy comes from.
Here we have this carbon.
And we have just let those wave
functions on the carbon itself
constructively and destructively
interfere.
Now we are going to make bonds.
Now we are going to take these
hybrid wave functions and let
them overlap with a wave
function, an atomic function
from another atom.
Now we are going to start to
make the bonds.
Here it goes.
We are bringing in a hydrogen,
making a bond,
bringing in a hydrogen,
bringing in another hydrogen,
and now we've got methane.
What did we do to do this?
What we did is we took that
sp^3 wave function on carbon and
then brought in the hydrogen
atom with its 1s wave function.
And we let it overlap.
Now there is constructive
interference right in here,
or destructive interference.
And the result is now a new
bond.
A result is this constructive
interference between this sp 3
wave function and the
1s wave function.
We are going to call that a
sigma bond.
It is sigma because that wave
function is symmetric along the
C-H axis.
It is cylindrically symmetric
along the C-H axis.
So this is a new bond.
That bond is the sigma bond,
composed of the carbon two sp 3
and the hydrogen 1s.
And so we've got two electrons,
now, in each one of those sp 3
states.
Now, the question is,
where did this energy come from
for that hybridization?
Remember we had to promote an
electron to do this trick here?
So where did this come from?
Well, where it comes from is
from the bond formation.
When you form a carbon-hydrogen
bond, you are going to release
some energy.
It is lower energy.
You are going to release some
energy.
And that energy for the
hybridization comes from that
bond formation.
In other words,
when you make the CH bond,
that is going to be an
exothermic process,
you are going to release
energy, but because you had to
do this electron promotion,
the amount of energy you are
going to release when you make
that C-H bond is not all that
you could have released if you
didn't have to do this
hybridization,
if you didn't have to do this
electron promotion.
So that energy,
to promote the electron,
comes from the actual C-H bond
formation.
Now, here is my carbon with
just the sp 3 wave
functions.
I haven't gotten that bonded to
anything in this picture.
What I am going to do is I am
going to rotate this around,
and it will be for a reason.
I just rotated it around.
And one electron in each one of
the sp three states.
Now what I am going to do is I
am going to bring in another
carbon, sp 3 hybridized
carbon, along this axis here.
That is why I turned this
around.
Here comes the other sp 3
hybridized carbon.
And I am going to let these two
sp 3 hybrid wave functions
overlap, so that now one of my
sp 3 states has two electrons in
it.
What am I doing right here?
I am letting those two sp 3
wave functions overlap,
constructive interference.
I am going to make another
bond, a sigma bond,
because this wave function is
cylindrically symmetric around
that axis.
That is a sigma bond.
It is a sigma bond composed of
the carbon 2sp 3
hybrid wave function and another
carbon 2sp 3 hybrid wave
function.
I just formed a carbon-carbon
bond.
I just brought in some
hydrogens.
In each case,
I now have overlap between the
1s wave function and the sp 3
wave function of the carbon,
and the molecule that I have is
ethane.
And this angle here is 109
degrees, right?
It is 109 degrees,
because you had that
tetrahedral configuration around
the carbon.
Because that is how the 2s wave
functions and the three 2p wave
functions around the carbon
constructively and destructively
interfered to give you that
tetrahedral shape for the sp 3
wave functions.
Oh, I thought we were going to
do this more closely.
Sorry.
All right.
We made these C-H bonds here.
They are all sigma bonds,
also.
That's carbon,
this sp 3 hybridization for
carbon.
But other atoms can also
undergo this sp 3 hybridization.
And one of those atoms here is
nitrogen.
Here is the electron
configuration for nitrogen.
In this case,
we have got two electrons in
the 2s state,
and then one in each one of the
2p states.
What we are going to do here
is, we're going to allow now
these four wave functions to
constructively and destructively
interfere, do what we call
hybridize.
And the result will be,
again, four sp 3 wave
functions.
Except the difference is that
because we have one more
electron in nitrogen,
one of these sp 3
states has already got two
electrons in it.
It is not going to be available
for bonding, in a moment.
In nitrogen,
the electron arrangement,
or the wave function
arrangement is also tetrahedral,
sp 3 to this corner,
sp 3, sp 3, sp 3.
Except that one of these sp 3
wave functions really is kind of
two sp 3 wave functions.
There are two electrons here in
this state.
This is the lone pair on the
nitrogen, and then sp3
hybridized nitrogen atom.
This is the lone pair pointed
at one of these vertices,
but then each one of these
lobes just represents one
electron.
So they are going to be
available for bonding.
What are we going to do here?
We are going to bring in some
hydrogens.
Here is a hydrogen.
Here is a hydrogen coming in.
We have got ammonia.
What did we do to form these
nitrogen-hydrogen bonds?
Well, we took that sp 3 wave
function on nitrogen and brought
in the hydrogen,
let that 1s wave function
constructively and destructively
interfere with that sp 3 wave
function.
The result is a sigma bond.
It is sigma.
It is composed of the nitrogen
2sp 3 and the hydrogen 1s wave
function.
Now, the angle right in here,
the angle, the
hydrogen-nitrogen-hydrogen angle
here, I want you to see that it
is actually a little smaller
than the ideal tetrahedral
angle.
It is no longer 109.5 degrees.
It is 107 degrees.
And the reason for that is
because of this lone pair out
here.
This lone pair has a very
repulsive interaction with the
electrons in these
nitrogen-hydrogen bonds here,
bringing that angle in a little
bit more close.
They are being repelled.
And so that will generally be
the case.
If you've got a lone pair of
electrons somewhere,
that will tend to repel,
everything will be repelled
from it.
And the consequence is that
this angle, this bond angle
here, is going to be a little
smaller than a tetrahedral angle
of 109.5 degrees.
But now, here is a really
important point.
You are often asked for,
what is the geometry around
some atom?
In this case,
you might be asked for,
what is the geometry around
nitrogen?
When you are asked such a
question, what it means is they
are asking you,
what is the geometry of the
atoms around the nitrogen?
Not the electrons.
The distinction is that the
geometry of the electrons around
this atom is about tetrahedral.
But usually,
one isn't interested in that.
Usually one is interested in
what is the geometry of the
other atoms around the nitrogen.
And so, in this case here,
the geometry of the other atoms
is a trigonal pyramidal
geometry.
It is not tetrahedral.
If you are asked for the shape
of the nitrogen molecule,
the answer is a trigonal
pyramid, not a tetrahedron.
That is really important.
That trips up a lot of people.
So the lone pairs pointing out
here, the electron geometry is
approximately tetetrahedral,
but that is not what we are
usually interested in.
We are interested in where the
atoms are, so the geometry is a
trigonal pyramid.
That is the sp 3
hybridization on ammonia or on
nitrogen.
Oxygen can also undergo this sp
3 hybridization.
Here is the electron
configuration for an oxygen
atom, two electrons in the 2s
and four in the 2p states.
What we are going to do here
again is we are going to let
these wave functions
constructively and destructively
interfere.
When we do that,
again, we are going to get four
new wave functions,
the sp 3 hybrid wave
functions.
But in the case of oxygen,
because we have one more
electron than that of nitrogen,
we are going to have two
electrons in that sp 3 state and
two electrons in the other sp 3
state.
And then one electron each in
the sp 3 states.
What is the electron
arrangement around oxygen going
to look like?
Well, it is going to look like
this, where, again,
each one of these sp 3 wave
functions is pointed to-- is
there a question over here that
I can help somebody with?
OK.
Each one of these wave
functions is pointed to a corner
of this tetrahedron.
But, again, one of these wave
functions represents two
electrons, this lone pair,
another one represents two
electrons, that lone pair,
and then only these two sp 3
wave functions are going to be
available for overlap with
another atom.
Let's bring another atom in.
Hydrogen is our atom of choice
today.
We have just made the water
molecule.
What did we do?
We took that sp^3 wave function
on oxygen and brought in a
hydrogen, overlapped them,
and formed a sigma bond.
A sigma bond between oxygen 2
sp 3 and hydrogen 1s.
That is a sigma bond.
Now, notice this angle here.
It is 104.5 degrees.
It is even smaller than 107
degrees.
And 107 was smaller than the
tetrahedral angle of 109.5.
Why?
Well, because we got these two
lone pairs here of electrons.
They're sticking out there.
They really are repulsive to
all the atoms around them.
And so all the other atoms,
these two hydrogens here really
try to get away from these two
lone pairs.
And so this angle here,
the hydrogen-oxygen-hydrogen
angle is even smaller than that
in ammonia and much smaller than
that in an ideal tetrahedron.
It is 104.5 degrees.
If you were asked for the
geometry of this molecule,
what would you say?
Sorry?
Bent.
All right, it is bent.
It is also planar,
right?
Hey, this is a no-brainer.
If you've got three atoms,
the molecule is planar.
Three points to find a plane.
And then the question is
whether or not those three atoms
are linear, in a line,
or whether they are bent?
And so, in this case,
for the water molecule,
this is a bent planar
arrangement.
That is the atom arrangement.
That is not the electron
arrangement.
The electron arrangement is
approximately tetrahedral.
But, again, usually you're
going to be asked for the atomic
arrangement.
The geometry around the oxygen,
well, this is a planar bent
molecule with the two lone pairs
sticking out here.
And, hey, you know what?
I want you to remember these
two lone pairs on water.
Very important because I think
Wednesday we are going to talk
about something called hydrogen
bonding.
And these two lone pairs play a
very critical role in hydrogen
bonding.
We have just covered this sp 3
hybridization.
There are other ways in which
the s wave functions and the p
wave functions can
constructively and destructively
interfere.
And to illustrate that,
I am going to start with this
atom boron, one less electron
than carbon.
So a different kind of a
hybridization now.
In the case of boron,
we are also going to have to do
this electron promotion.
We just move that 2s electron
up to a 2p state,
so now we've got three wave
functions, 2s,
2p, 2px, 2py.
We've got three populated
states, and we are going to let
them hybridize.
And when we let them hybridize,
what we are going to get are
three what we call sp 2
wave functions,
each with one electron.
Let me try to explain that.
These are the wave functions
that we've got after this
electron promotion,
one wave function for that one
electron in the 2s state on
boron, it's spherically
symmetric.
One 2px.
One electron represented by the
2py wave function,
here it is.
What we are going to do now is
to let these three wave
functions, not four like in sp 3
hybridization,
but these three wave functions
constructively and destructively
interfere.
And when we do that we are
going to get what we call sp 2
wave functions.
Or, sp 2 hybrid wave
functions or hybrid orbitals.
They all look the same.
They are just oriented
differently.
These three wave functions all
lie in one plane.
The sp 2 all lies in one plane,
unlike sp 3 hybrid wave
functions.
And so what I am going to do is
take these three wave functions
now.
Since they all have the same
origin, I am going to plot them
on the same graph,
and they are going to look like
this.
Again, I am going to leave out
this little negative lobe here,
the little negative part of the
wave function.
Just for clarity in this
drawing, I just show you the
positive part of the wave
function.
And the positive parts,
the maxima of the positive
parts of those wave functions,
lie in one plane.
And the angle between these
wave functions is 120 degrees,
each one of them.
This is the sp^2-hybridization
on boron, one electron in each
one of the sp 2 states.
I am going to bring in a
hydrogen now,
bring in another hydrogen,
and bring in another hydrogen.
Hey, I've got BH three.
So what did we do?
Well, with each one of these
hydrogens we made a sigma bond.
It is sigma because it is
cylindrically symmetric around
that axis.
It is a sigma bond composed of
boron, 2sp 2
overlapping with a hydrogen 1s
bond.
This molecule here is planar
because these hybrid wave
functions all lie in the same
plane.
We call this trigonal planar
because there is an angle of 120
degrees between each
hydrogen-boron-hydrogen,
or these
hydrogen-boron-hydrogen angles
are all 120 degrees.
It is trigonal planar.
Well, carbon,
it can also undergo this sp^2
hybridization.
It can undergo sp^3,
but it can also undergo sp^2
hybridization.
We have to do an electron
promotion again.
We did that.
We are going to let them
hybridize to sp^2.
The result is three sp^2 wave
functions, and one of the 2p
wave functions is left alone.
We are going to label it 2py.
That one is not going to
participate in this
hybridization.
A picture is here are the
individual atomic wave functions
on carbon, and I am going to let
just these three hybridize to
make three sp 2 hybrid orbits,
or three sp 2 hybrid wave
functions.
And they have identically the
same shapes as they did for
boron.
And then this guy hasn't been
touched.
It is still the atomic wave
function, 2py.
Yes?
Because you've got different
kinds of environments.
Some environments allow these
three wave functions to
constructively and destructively
appear.
Others will allow all the four
to constructively and
destructively be interfered.
Thermodynamics,
okay?
Whether you're going to form
here ethane or ethylene is a
function of a lot of other
parameters.
No, until we get to
thermodynamics and then you are.
We will get to that,
Okay?
Okay.
You are quite welcome.
That is all right.
Because I know this is a little
bit abstract,
but it is actually the case.
Which one you're going to form,
ethane or ethylene depends on
what other constituents you've
got around.
It is going to depend on the
relative pressures of your
carbon and your hydrogen.
In this case here,
because we have the same
origin, I am now going to put
these three wave functions on
top of each other.
Plot them in the same graph.
They are going to look like
they did in the case of boron.
I think we will pick it up
there on Wednesday.
See you then.